"Loki'' has been a massive success for Marvel
Studios and Disney+, and the series remains
popular with the die-hard MCU fans.
The penultimate episode, "Journey Into Mystery"
— itself a nod to the name of the 1960s
comic book in which Loki and Thor first appeared
– was full of "Loki'' Easter eggs that had
fans across the internet dissecting every
frame to find fun little comic book nods.
This was particularly true of the vast wasteland
in the void at the end of time, which was
full of MCU relics, including the Dark Aster
— which is a ship that is associated with
Ronan The Accuser, Yellowjacket's helmet — remember
him?
From Ant-Man, and the remains of a ruined
Avengers Tower.
This is called Qeng — an intriguing easter
egg itself.
In the comics, Qeng Enterprises bought the
old Avengers Building from Tony Stark, and
it turns out that Qeng had a direct relationship
with Kang the Conqueror!
The Kang-MCU rumors have been floating around
for years now.
We also met a whole new gaggle of Loki variants,
in addition to the group which debuted in
the Episode 4 post-credits scene.
While spotting the Thanos Copter in the void
was one of the coolest Easter eggs in the
entire MCU, because who doesn’t love them
some Thanos Copter?
— There was one other that joined it at
the top of the ranks.
Episode 5 pulled one of the most beloved — and
often poked fun at — characters straight
from the Marvel pages and threw him right
into "Loki."
This moment was also doubly special as it
included a special cameo from Chris Hemsworth
himself, which many viewers of the episode
likely missed.
Just shy of 10 minutes into Episode 5, Loki
is traveling with his newfound group of fellow
Lokis, bound for the shelter of their underground
bunker.
As the camera pans from above ground to the
hidden lair, a major Easter egg hides in the
dirt.
Stuck in a jar that reads T365 is a miniature
Thor, who turns out to be the Toad of Thunder:
Throg . Guess you could say that the jar is
some sort of…
“Frog protection.
Fraud protection.
Yeah, frog, fraud, frog, fraud.
I think we’re on the same page.
We’re totally on the same page”
The tiny — but mighty — amphibian jumps
around in the jar, attempting to reach Mjolnir.
While he does this, he lets out a few grunts
of frustration.
And according to "Loki" director Kate Herron,
these grunts were actually recorded by Chris
Hemsworth himself!
Herron clarified that these noises were not
recycled from any previous films - Hemsworth
actually did all new voice work - well, grunt-work,
just for Loki.
Fans were hoping to get some sort of cameo
from the Australian actor in "Loki," and this
was just the perfect way to do it without
having him steal the spotlight from his on-screen
brother.
“Sorry about that time I turned you into
a frog.”
“It was a wonderful joke!”
As "Loki" writer Eric Martin revealed during
his live-tweet screening of Episode 5, fans
could have seen Throg much sooner.
"We actually shot a scene for the Time Theater
in Ep 1 of Loki getting pummeled by Frog Thor,
but had to cut it to keep things moving.
It's too bad, because Tom was funny as hell."
Hemsworth will also lend his voice to Thor
in the upcoming MCU series, "What If...?,"
which is set to debut on Disney+ on August
11th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.